Kevin Durant hasn't played in front of
Warriors fans in quite a while since
2019 to be exact so why has it taken 4
years for Katie to play in front of dub
Nation after the 2019 NBA Finals he left
the Warriors to join the Nets and KD
wouldn't return to action until the year
after because of his torn Achilles so he
missed his first opportunity in year one
with Brooklyn once he returned from
injury ktie finally played the Warriors
in the bay in 2021 he would return to
the chase Center but there was a problem
the fans weren't allowed in the building
due to the co 19 pandemic after fans
came back in 202 to KD was finally set
to play in front of dub Nation but he
sprained his left MCL against the
Pelicans CED him a January meet up in
San Francisco and it gets even weirder
in the 2022 23 season before he was
traded to the Suns KD sprained the MCL
in his right knee and then after he was
traded to the Suns this happened during
warm-ups which made him miss another
chance to play in San Francisco in front
of the fans the streak will finally end
at the start of the 2023 season but what
an odd Journey for KD